[Music]
it's a again my pleasure to make the
next introduction we've talked about our
students I think most important product
as many people said this institution is
our students of course we they couldn't
do as well and we couldn't do as well
for them
if research wasn't our main
preoccupation Steve Koonin was one of
our students and I'm happy to say he is
PhD with me got it in 1975 I remember by
the time he had by the time I let him go
we had published four or five papers
which is not the average for your
average PhD student
since then he's went back to Caltech
where it came from and he's a professor
physics there as involved in many
national issues and happens to be a
member of the town's panel which many of
us have spent a lot of time agonizing on
the results of and he's also been on
many other important national committees
that have made decisions welcome back
Steve and I might I think
is the microphone on yeah well we've
heard a number of speculations today
about why OH&S chose to throw a big
party for its 46th anniversary I'd like
to add another speculation to the list
during the cold fusion flop a few years
ago I got to know rich Petra so at the
Center for plasma fusion here rich
believes and I guess I agree with him
that it's no coincidence that not only
is 46 the age of the laboratory for
nuclear science but it's also the atomic
number for palladium month or a month
and a half ago when I was talking to
ligue Watson's about what I might tell
you about in this talk he gave the
guidance that I should reminisce a
little bit and then talk about some
physics that's germane to gallon s as
far as memories go I'd note that my
formal connection with the LNS through
the CTP I was authors student really
only lasted for three years from 1972 to
75 and so I don't have much of a stock
of anecdotes to tell you about I would
remark that during those years I learned
an awful lot from a number of very good
teachers and I still enjoy interacting
with them usually today as colleagues as
far as physics goes I thought what I
would do in this talk is to pick up on a
theme that I started when I was a
graduate student or show you or remind
for you some of the things we did then
and then give you some sense of where
it's gone and what some of the prospects
are in this business the general theme
is the use of the supercomputer for
large-scale computing generally or to
understand nuclear hydronic many-body
phenomenon it's by now almost truism
that computing has really changed the
way the world is and that's particularly
true in the way in which we do research
in nuclear physics and many-body physics
were often confronted with the fact that
we know the theory but we don't know the
solutions so it here it's not perhaps
like the drought that currently exists
in particle physics where people feel
that there are no new phenomena to study
here there are plenty of phenomena it's
not the Lagrangian or the Hamiltonian
we're looking for but rather it's the
new qualitative behavior that happens in
the solutions when there are many
degrees of freedom so although we might
know Newton's laws for a system in many
classical particles or the Hamiltonian
for a many-body system of the kranji and
for QCD we have no way of directly
solving the equations furthermore at
least for nuclear and elementary
particle physics we have no direct
visualization of what happens and so one
can therefore resort to the use of
large-scale computing supercomputing or
to try to solve these equations and get
some feeling for what's going on and of
course as always when you have an
enormous amount of data coming out of
the computer the whole issue of
visualization becomes essential and a
very important part of the process what
I want to do today is is to go through a
little bit of three different stories
one is a brief recollection and perhaps
update on the TD hf model the
time-dependent hartree-fock model for
nuclear collisions the damped heavy ion
collisions that Herman was talking about
I'll then show you how that's evolved
into something that I'm quite excited
about and that's the treatment of the
nuclear shell model using Monte Carlo
methods in some sense generalizing the
time-dependent hartree-fock and then
we'll switch gears a little bit and talk
about proton proton or baryon barrier
and collisions actually and we'll look
at some simulations of the scre model
for the collisions of nucleons
so let me remind you before we get
started of what the mean field picture
is of nuclei are more generally of many
particle systems what one can say is
that the idea is that each particle is
going to move independently throughout
the system or throughout the nucleus
each nucleon under the average influence
of all of the others formally that can
be stated in the following way if you
start with a Hamiltonian that looks like
some one body part here a dagger and a
of the creation and annihilation
operators for the fermions
and some two body interaction if you
then make the formal assumption that the
wavefunction for the system which in
general is a function of all of the
coordinates of the systems factors into
a product of functions of the individual
coordinates appropriately anti
symmetrized is greater determinant you
put that into these equations and then
you get for example a set of static
equations describing the time
independent solutions of this problem or
a set of time dependent Hawtree Fock
equations describing the time dependence
of this problem each of these has the
form of a single particle equation for
each of the wave functions one at a time
in one case involving the eigenvalue in
the other case involving a time
derivative the Hamiltonian appearing in
the equation involves the same one body
part and then a second one body part
which depends upon the strength of the
interaction and then the mean field
which in turn depends upon what all of
the other particles are doing so this
reduces the original linear Schrodinger
equation in many dimensions to a set of
nonlinear partial differential equations
either eigenvalues or time-dependent
problems for the static or dynamical
properties of the system
in thinking about the history of how
mean-field physics has evolved it was
quite interesting to go back and try to
tick off the people involved and realize
the number of developments that occurred
here at the laboratory for nuclear
science of course the whole idea
physically was started for atomic
physics back in the 30s with the Hawtree
fog method in the late 40s the
systematics of nuclear properties
binding energies ground state spins and
so on started to suggest that in fact
the idea for nuclei was not so
outrageous but it was very difficult to
understand how to reconcile the notion
of nucleons moving freely through the
nucleus with the idea that the nuclear
matter making up the nucleus is a
strongly correlated system Viki
Weisskopf mentioned that this morning
der pol extra contributed a lot to
trying to resolve that apparent
contradiction in our understanding of
nuclear matter well by the time the late
60s had come around people began to take
the idea rather seriously and a number
of advances in our understanding of
nuclear matter together with in advance
in the power of computers but people to
try to solve nuclear hartree-fock
equations for the static system using
effective interactions and here there
were two schools of development one
initiated by skirm and followed up by
Dominick Voltron a new bear floor car
who were frequent visitors here
parameterize the effective interaction
between nucleons in terms of order six
parameters the so called skirm
interaction and then proceeded by fixing
those parameters comparing with the
gross properties of nuclei to calculate
the properties of specific nuclei Jon
Nedley are originally working with Hans
bethe at Cornell and then later here
pursued a different approach in which he
tried to establish the effective
interactions from the properties of
nuclear matter I think in the end one
came to realize that these were two
essentially equivalent ways of tackling
the same problem
these effective interactions in the
static calculations proved to be a very
good description of the gross properties
of nuclei energies densities shapes and
so on just to show you how good things
were John
Nedley will recognize this figure this
is a plot of the charge density for a
whole sequence of nuclei a comparison
between the mean field theory and the
experiment as determined through sample
from electron scattering for nuclei
ranging from oxygen to red 208 well all
about the time that I showed up on the
scene in the early 70s a number of us
had the idea of trying to solve the time
dependent equations for the same kind of
effective interactions the motivation as
I will discuss in a moment was centered
on trying to describe the collisions
between two large nuclei and here a
particular important was the work of
Paul Bosch who was at that time a
visitor from Saturday author Kerman
continually provided guidance Mike
Strayer Lord Weiss Tom Davies and so on
all played a role in trying to make
these calculations happen and I'll show
you some of those along about 1980 there
was some other very important work that
was done here primarily by Shimon Levite
working with John Nedley and then by
Yiruma Hassid was there barely owned and
myself on a Neroni with the question of
what does it all mean given that you can
solve these nonlinear equations that
describe the static or time-dependent
hartree-fock system how do I connect
that with the real system a fundamental
problem here is that the Schrodinger
equation is linear
while the hartree-fock equations are
nonlinear and trying to understand then
how to make the connection with
conventional quantum mechanics which I
think we eventually did do was the issue
in the early eighties along about the
mid 80s there were some interesting
applications of the numerical methods
that we developed originally in the
early 70s to problems in atomic physics
in particular charge transfer between
two fast atoms and the behavior of atoms
under the influence of strong laser
pulses where one uses the T dhf
equations to follow the evolution of the
atomic electrons in about 1986 a
graduate student of mine Gail Sugiyama
and I looked at a generalization of the
T dhf equations which I'll describe for
you are called the auxiliary field Monte
Carlo method in which use one used many
mean fields to try to get exact
solutions to quantum mechanical
many-body problems this was picked up by
Jorge Hersh and a host of other people
who were slightly after that time
worried about how to solve the Hubbard
model and trying to understand how
temperature superconductivity and then
in about 1990 or so we began to think
about seriously applying these ideas
through the nuclear shell model as I'll
describe for you this is work that's
being done by Calvin Johnson Eric Orman
who were postdocs at Caltech lattice
clang a very talented graduate student
and myself I should note that Calvin was
in some sense an LNS product although
several generations removed Calvin was a
student of Wieck Haxton at Seattle which
in turn was a student of Dirk well
that's at Stanford and of course Dirk
was a student here under Vicki okay
so the motivation at the time in the
early 70s was to try to understand heavy
iron collisions and of course the
collision between two large nuclei
schematically illustrated here is very
different from the collision between a
single nucleon or an alpha particle and
a nucleus one has the possibility of
affecting nuclei in very dramatic ways
we know now that one can make nuclei
spin fast enough so that the angular
momentum is a significant influence on
their structure we can pump more than
100 H bar into a nucleus we can make
nuclei very far from the line of beta
stability with unusual Neutron or proton
numbers we can heat nuclei to
temperatures of several MeV 4 or 5 MeV
study their behavior electromagnetic
properties shapes we can also compress
them perhaps at ultra relativistic
collisions to very high densities and
perhaps create the quark-gluon plasma
that I suspect we'll hear about tomorrow
the driving issue at the time was that
one saw that at low energies the system
behaved in rather unexpected way
Herman mentioned the two nuclei would
come together exchange a lot of energy
but not exchange very much in the way of
particles and could one understand this
in terms of the dynamics of a very large
newly degenerate Fermi system so what we
did was in fact at the time to set up
the time-dependent hartree-fock
equations in which one could follow
using the same effective interactions
the development of the single particle
wave function for each nucleon during
the collision provence and myself and
and john Negley started by considering
the very simplest system namely slabs of
nuclear matter colliding in effectively
one dimension we set the equations up on
the LNS computer which at that time was
an IBM 360 something or other i don't
remember exactly what it was and that
there was great interest as the results
started to come out day after day
typically overnight or every second
night into what these equations would do
I remember heated arguments in author's
office in which the opinions ranged from
well they would just go through each
other and nothing would happen at all to
that they would stick together and you
would discover the compound nucleus
these days one can do the calculations
in three dimensions one stores of order
ten of v variables on a very fast
computer of course typically several
hours of a Cray 1 time per collision one
can study the collision at different
energies and impact parameters and then
compare with the data and one finds many
unusual features that are directly
related or to the quantum mechanical
behavior of the systems under study let
me show you a video which was done at
Livermore a number of years ago by Moore
twice and his collaborators which is a
simulation of some of these calculations
or it's not a simulation of the
calculations it's the output of the
calculations visualization so if we
could run the video
hello there we go so these are
simulations of a collision of Krypton
with lanthanum moderately large nuclei
at a laboratory energy of 505 MeV
they're done using the skirm or
effective interaction what we do is to
set the two nuclei Krypton and lanthanum
up and boost them toward each other and
watch the density evolving during the
collision a typical length scale is
about eight Fermi's or so across and a
typical time of the entire collision is
a few times ten to the minus twenty-one
seconds this is a head-on collision at
zero h bar and one is watching the
densities evolve you notice how well
defined the two nuclei are even though
they've as Herman said have gotten into
bed with each other and are exchanging
particles I believe that these guys
separate them after the collision very
slowly you can watch the next snapping
over here you notice the pronounced
optical deformation of the nuclei it's
across the strong force the volume
energy and the surface energy that's
playing against the Coulomb force here
which is quite significant for these
heavy nuclei okay we've now moved up to
27 h-bar or so you notice that as the
collision proceeds all kinds of funny
bumps and Wiggles appear along the edges
these are not numerical artifacts but
are due to the motion of the particular
single particle wave functions coursing
through the combined potential well of
the two systems and banging against the
walls these guys stick as they slowly
rotate and they will stick together for
as long as you're willing to pay the
computer bill
okay we're gonna crank up the angular
went them now to 84 h-bar
this presumably would form a compound
nucleus if it sticks these guys come
upon huh I'm not sure ah they come apart
during the collision of course a great
amount of the initial kinetic energy of
the system is pumped into the internal
excitation of these fragments which come
apart very deformed and moving much more
slowly than what they came in with and
of course spinning as well one loses
orbital angular momentum into internal
rotation of the system 105 h-bar
rather more rapid separation
when we were doing these one-dimensional
calculations at the very beginning in
the early 70s it was a great feat to be
able to even put up the one-dimensional
pictures in black and white on the CRT
it took typically half a minute of
intervention on the computer operators
part in order to draw one frame now of
course you can do this essentially on a
PC things have evolved significantly you
can see how they're spinning that
spinning of course is eventually
reflected in many gamma rays that are
admitted by the spinning fragments as it
cascades down and loses its angular
momentum 250 which is a rather
peripheral collision you can see a
little bit of Coulomb excitation as the
surfaces don't quite kiss one another
they come apart
and then finally we can see several
collisions at once his 5h bar 84 and the
250 you can get a sense of the different
time scales involved
we're gonna freeze the lower one now and
let the other two proceed and see how
the different time scales and different
scattering angles result from the
different initial conditions
Oh
that's enough right now we'll come back
in a moment could we hold that one for a
second let me just show you the kind of
things that one is able to reproduce
here is the same kind of plot that
Herman was showing you see you might
want to try to cut the projector off
okay good we're looking here at a
collision of Krypton on bismuth one
plots the energy of the fragments
observed against the angle at which
they're observed one sees a rather
complicated structure of the
cross-section in the data and one is
rather satisfied that the T dhf
calculations can reproduce the angle and
energy a variation of the average of the
structure similarly here is a much
heavier system xenon on bismuth
essentially all of the fragments are
focused very near the grazing angle and
again the T dhf reproduces that one of
the issues of T dhf is how does one
extend its validity up to higher
energies and I would have to state nor
honesty that that's a subject of still
serious research one has the sense that
these mean field theories will work at
low energies but at higher energies the
Pauli principle becomes a less effective
and the whole idea of an independent
particle system begins to break down
okay so much for T dhf let me then talk
a little bit about the second topic
which in fact grows out of T dhf in a
rather peculiar way and that's the whole
issue of trying to solve the nuclear
shell model by using Monte Carlo if you
ask any nuclear physicist what is your
best description of the nucleus you
would in fact probably get the answer of
a nuclear shell model in that system
one takes a set of some number of
nucleons a nucleons distributes them
over in levels the Hamiltonian one
writes down consists of the single
particle energies and this two body
interaction and then you proceed to
simply diagonalize that Hamiltonian in a
basis the basis of configurations of
these nucleons spread among the levels
one it's enthusiasm for the model
however is tempered when you start to
make a calculation of how big a basis
need if I don't worry about symmetry
such as angular momentum or ISO spin but
simply count the number of ways in which
I can distribute these a nucleons over
the N levels that's a course of binomial
coefficient which varies very rapidly
and increases very rapidly as either n
or a increases in fact increases
exponentially generally what that means
in practical terms is that direct
diagonalization of the shell model
Hamiltonian is hopeless beyond the SD
shell and in fact you cannot do full
calculations in the PF shell
nevertheless it's a widely held belief
among nuclear structure physicists that
if you could solve this shell model
Hamiltonian with appropriate
interactions that that would in fact
describe the entire richness of nuclear
structure that we see circle nuclei
deformations isomers all the things that
one talks about well one of the clues as
to how to proceed is to ask how is this
exact solution that one might be after
related to the mean field that we we can
in fact treat let me remind you that the
mean field the way it was constructed
the Hamiltonian involved a one body
operator representing the single
particle levels and a second one body
operator whose strength depended upon
the mean field Sigma and of course the
interaction as well what shamone levite
in the early 80s taught us in nuclear
physics and in fact was known to a
number of people in statistical
mechanics for almost 15 years before was
that it is possible to write the exact
evolution operator of the system so H
here is the exact Hamiltonian it's
exponential is some terribly complicated
many-body operator as in fact a linear
superposition of Exponential's of one
body operators which we know how to
handle this linear superposition being a
sum over all possible mean fields with
some Gaussian weighting associated with
the mean field and so this opens up the
possibility if you can arrange to do the
sum over all possible mean field
of learning how to handle this exact
partition function operator and
consequently make exact statements about
the many-body system for example if
you're interested in the thermal average
at some temperature one over beta of the
Hamiltonian you can write that as the
ratio of two sums over all mean fields
one of which has a slightly different
sum and than the other these should be
little anxious which is of course the
basis for the whole method this method
is for example the method that's used to
treat the hubbard model in
investigations of high-temperature
superconductivity and copper oxide
points well the idea is to evaluate this
average by a Monte Carlo sampling over
all mean fields this has a tremendous
advantage over the direct
diagonalization method for the shell
model one has to deal here only with in
by n matrices the size of the number of
orbitals in the problem and not in
factorial by n factorial matrices which
is the size of the basis if you like in
the problem and so it has a very
favorable scaling with the size of the
shell model problem moreover this method
is ideal for parallel computer
architectures since you're doing a Monte
Carlo and the Monte Carlo is not a
terribly large problem what you can do
is form out the Monte Carlo to many
independent processors if you have 64
processors you can do 64 different monte
callers at once and then simply collect
the statistics and in fact the results
that I'll show you some of them in a
moment
were in fact done using the Intel gamma
machine at Caltech which is a 64 node
machine there's a 512 node machine
that's just started running and of
course that will be 8 times better as a
test case we've recently been looking at
particles in the SD shell for which we
can do the exact diagonalization and
test the method in which the force we've
taken is an ISO vector pairing force
plus quadrupole quadrupole and hexa
Decker polhacks Dekker pole interactions
I should remark before I show you the
results that not only can one do the
breakup of the Hamiltonian in terms of
the density but one can also do it in
terms of the
and operators which is perhaps more
appropriate for the nuclear force which
we know has a strong faring component
here's one example which has come off
the computer in the last couple weeks
what I'm showing you is a calculation of
one species of nucleons approximately
six in the SD shelf
using the interaction that I discussed
pairing plus multipole we're working in
the grand canonical formulation so that
we have a chemical potential and sum
over all possible numbers pairing
decomposition as I noted plotted on the
bottom here is the number of time slices
used in the Monte Carlo in numerical
parameter ideally one would like to take
Delta beta to zero what's shown all the
Monte Carlo results as a function of
Delta beta for various Delta beta this
corresponding to about ten time slices
the mean field result is way up there
and the exact result is down there and
you can see that there is in fact a very
good extrapolation no one has some sense
that this is in fact going to work
another observable you can calculate is
the mean square angular momentum in the
system it starts out at some rather high
number mean field is all the way up
there the exact answer is of course very
small this is a temperature of one MeV
and you can see again a very good
extrapolation or downward to the exact
answer we've gotten more ambitious in
the last few weeks
and we're now trying to do protons and
neutrons together this is a calculation
in which we're trying to refine a trial
state which consists of four nucleons in
the d5 halves orbital two protons and
two neutrons into the exact solution in
the full as d shell with this pairing
plus quadrupole plus X a decouple
interaction the Monte Carlo points are
these red symbols we're a little bit
concerned about that one the our best
guess at the moment as to what the exact
solution is is this one I think all one
can conclude from this point is that the
calculations are feasible the energy is
coming down whether we've got this
exactly right or not who presumably know
in a couple of weeks
equally encouraging is that you can take
the square of the angular momentum and
calculate it it starts off at some
rather high value because we've assumed
it to form trial state but then drops
very nicely down to a very small value
consistent with the zero that we know it
has to be as the temperature gets lower
and lower so what I've shown you were
perfectly feasible test calculations one
is looking I think it's some very
exciting future applications assuming
everything works you can calculate
strength functions for hot nuclei or in
fact for nuclear ground states for your
favorite operators gamal tower of
quadrupole operators whatever you can
calculate the level densities and the
influence of the residual interaction on
them these are costs determined very
much the behavior of what happens in
Vickie's evaporation formula one would
like to know how the residual
interaction effects the level densities
you can crank the system study high spin
structure and so on so on in fact quite
excited about what might happen in the
near future with those calculations
okay so that was topic two let me then
turn to topic three which is a different
kind of supercomputer application not
two nuclei but two nucleons and this is
a visualization of the squirming on
model of nucleons the general background
is as follows we have very strong
evidence now that the correct theory of
the strong forces QCD quarks bound
together by gluons but in fact we can't
QCD in many interesting cases nobody can
start from the QCD Lagrangian and tell
you what the mass of the proton is there
are in course numerous efforts along
these lines most prominently lattice
gauge theories but I think was still a
long way from having convincing results
and so for many cases people have
resorted to effective theories one such
effective theory one can build as a
theory of interacting mesons so you do
away with the clocks and gluons entirely
you just talk about massan's and in
particular about two kinds of mesons and
the squirming on model a pie Maison and
the Sigma Maison or the PI comes in
three flavors from I so spin or three
charge states flavors is the wrong word
three kinds of pies and the Sigma field
and in fact it's rather surprising and
non-intuitive that you can build a
nucleon out of mesons only with the
appropriate nonlinear theory to do so
one has to mix the charge degrees of
freedom in the PI on together with the
space degrees of freedom basically to
make the PI on have a different charge
character depending where you are around
the nucleon it turns out that such an
object is a Fermi on and if you adjust
the parameters in the Lagrangian
correctly you can describe nuclear on
properties to an accuracy of about 30%
or so energy radius GA and things of
that sort
one of the interesting and fun things
you can do is that that's what happens
now if I take two of these squirming on
solutions and I try to collide them
together so look at the classical
equations of motion for this nonlinear
skirm we're on jian we've done that by
setting up ms on fields on a 20 by 60 by
40 lattice taking about two thousand
time steps and typically about an hour
of Cray time per collision if we could
run or just a little bit of the tape and
then stop it for a moment let's go ahead
and do that so this was done by Mike
summer and Ryoichi Seki and myself the
visualization which as I mentioned is a
non-trivial problem was done by Matt
class and undergraduate using some
facilities at Caltech and what we're
going to be looking at is first of all
screw me on screw me on collisions we
plot here the PI on field in the plane
and the red shows the baryon density of
the squirming ons this is at a kinetic
energy of 157 MeV an impact parameter of
point for fermius we're seeing the same
thing again you can see that they look
an awful lot like the TD HF pictures
they come together and bounce off each
other
here we are at an impact parameter of
1.2 Fermi's basically the same energy
time in Fermi of irsie is running on the
bottom let's say a significantly greater
interaction between the two a lot of
what looks like vorticity in the Payan
field here which is kind of interesting
again
okay could we hold this one for a second
just show you of course one can get some
sense here are the trajectories of the
baryon density as a function of Y and Z
2 different collision velocities and
different impact parameters you can get
some sense of what the system is doing
another fun thing to do is to quick is
to collide not screw me on what screw me
on but screw me on with anti squirming
on if you can build a proton you can
build an antiproton and just to remind
you experimental ii what happens this is
an emulsion picture of a antiproton
coming in coming to rest and then
blowing up a nucleon or nucleus some
large number of 4 or 5 pi ons
come out and this field has got this
theory has got pylons in it you might
ask what happens and so these are
simulations of a squirming on and anti
squirming on you can see the PI on field
pointing out over here and pointing in
over here
this is the anti squirming on this is
the squirming on let's go ahead and just
run it
gone you left the course with just
clients we're running the same thing
again so you can watch it these PI own
excitations will of course propagate
outward we're going to do the same thing
but at higher energies 500 MeV now and
an impact parameter of 1 Fermi these
pine excitations will cost propagate
outward till they become weak enough
that the theory becomes linear and then
they appear as pylons I think that's
about all
ok let me just show you what one can
extract from that you can try to plot as
a function of time the baryon number as
a function of time during the collision
and what's rather surprising is that the
annihilation happens rather rapidly
essentially at the cause of limit
independent of the bombarding energy as
I think you might have been able to get
a feel from those pictures another thing
you can do is to take the final
excitation of the pion field fourier
analyze it and try to predict the
spectrum and number of pi ons that come
out and here is an example of that
collision here is the number of pi ons
as a function of the PI on energy you
can see that it's peaked at around an
energy of 500 MeV there are two
squirming ons and the collision so you
have a total energy of 2,000 MeV one is
getting about four pi ons out of here
which is a little bit on the low side
but not terrible compared to what one
sees experimentally alright I think I've
probably just about used up my time so
let me stop at this point to thank you
for your attention
you